hi everyone thanks so much for joining
me today my name is Jacqueline Carville
and I'm work in marketing at DNA star
and so I'm here to introduce us briefly
so DNA star is a software company
located in beautiful Madison Wisconsin
we provide software applications for
molecular biology workflows protein
workflows for structural biologists and
and just work flows which will be
discussing more today so the speaker we
have here today is Matthew Kaiser he's
our senior manager of NGS applications
and he'll be discussing our variant
detection and validation control
workflow which is particularly useful
for many people doing NGS workflow is
also keeping doing clinical research as
well so with that I'll go ahead and pass
it over to man okay Thank You Jackie and
thank you everyone for joining us this
afternoon today we'll be talking about
DNA star software and some of the newer
workflows that we have in the software
where we can validate gene panel and
targeted Reese sequencing data sets and
use our software to determine accuracy
of the entire process so like to show
you an introduction to the company first
and then we'll take a look at some
screenshots of the ease of use of the
software as well as some of the results
so a little background to start out DNA
stars located in Madison Wisconsin
there's a nice picture here of Lake
Monona and the capital we're just down
the road from downtown Madison our
developers our sales team are mostly
located in the Madison location my role
at the company is to work with customers
on NGS projects I listen to customer
feedback I relay that to the development
team and really spend a lot of my time
and a support role what's nice about
having all of our folks located here at
Madison is that I have direct access to
the development team so i can really
relay in
information accurately and I think that
makes a big difference for a developing
top-notch software so DNA star software
is compatible with all the NGS platforms
of course alumina and ion torrent I'm
pacbio has been related increasing
presence especially for microbial genome
assembly and we still do some 454 as
well so what's nice about this type of
software is that it can accommodate oral
different platforms as well as all
different types of workflows and that
can be important especially for labs
that are doing more than one thing or
using more than one type of sequencing
instrument so one of the first questions
that we often get is what is the the
hardware requirements for this type of
software and this is a kind of a general
overview of the type of hardware they
might use it could be just a laptop
computer when we're doing alignments for
gene panels or exomes you do need to
have enough space on a hard drive and we
call this a scratch disk over here in
the scratch disk processes processes as
data as the assembly is running and so
for a gene panel that might be one
terabyte of space for a Rolex element
might be maybe two terabytes and so
forth so it's really this day and age a
fairly modest requirement and of course
you need enough storage for the type of
data that you have so it's something to
keep in mind nowadays most laptops have
enough RAM enough processing power to
handle quite a few gene panel projects
and exomes now for those of you that do
not have the hardware in place there are
other options and more recently DNA star
has moved our software up to the Amazon
Cloud and there's some advantages to
using cloud hardware one of them is that
you don't have to invest and maintain
your own Hardware amazon will will do
that investment for you maintain it and
it's always there so
so the way that we use this then we we
use our our laptop that's on the ground
and we use a DNA start protocol to
upload the data to the cloud the seek
man engine assembly is up somewhere is
up in the clouds we can run the assembly
then we set it up on our local computer
a processing power is used up in the
cloud the data can be stored up in the
cloud as well when it's done we can
return it back to our land computer and
do the analysis and so there's several
advantages one I find myself using the
cloud just out of convenience it's more
convenient for me to work on my laptop
and launch assemblies on a big powerful
computer than it is to walk over to my
big desktop computer in the other room
and run assemblies other times it may be
that you're traveling or working with a
collaborator and physically you're in a
different location where your data is
still central you can launch assemblies
you know when you're traveling it you
know in the hotel room i can run
assemblies but i forgot to run some for
a presentation so the cloud option then
has become a really nice option for our
customers and this is really gaining
traction and acceptance as people are
more comfortable putting data up on the
cloud I were to definitely seen a shift
of people using this kind of technology
another major component to DNA star is
the sought the software support that we
provide and if you go to our website
under the support section there's a
number of different training videos and
I know the font is quite small here but
you can see there's a number of ion
torrent and pacbio and alumina training
videos that are between you know 30
seconds and five minutes generally and
these are on specific topics NGS topics
and non NGS topics for different
molecular biology type workflows so it's
a great source there's I believe over
200 videos now on there also you'll
typically watch these through YouTube so
they're a great resource for our
customers then we also do monthly
webinars and the webinars are on
specific topics I've done a couple of
them this year one with ion torrent data
and alumina
similar to this webinar for accuracy I
have one coming up later this month for
microbial genome assembly so the
webinars are about an hour long I spend
some time introducing the software but
then the majority the time is spent in
the software with live software demo so
if there's a particular workflow that
you're interested in in addition to what
we're talking about today these webinars
are archived back to 2012 on all
different topics so I highly recommend
checking out some of the webinars if
you're interested so one of the first
questions that will get with DNA star
software is can desktop software be
powerful enough to handle large NGS data
sets and so I like to point people first
to the assembly speeds and these are
some of the benchmarks that we've gotten
these are actually going to get updated
soon but just even idea a whole human
genome which can be you know 1.2 billion
reads in this case almost 40 X coverage
takes about we call it 12 hours 13 hours
to both assemble and do the variant
analysis so we roll everything under the
hood and do it together we view the
alignment plus the variant analysis a
lot of programs will kind of do those
separately in separate steps these times
are going to improve quite a bit on some
of the newer mac computers in particular
that have some really nice hardware
components these times are going to be
dropping to about 8 to 9 hours so we'll
look for these to improve things like
exomes which are you know of course the
large car degree sequencing usually
generally say about two hours of gene
panels so an eye in torque panel or an
alumina panel are typically measured in
minutes so we get really really fast
assembly time and we've had these
assembly times for several years our
algorithm is designed to be very
efficient with large amounts of data and
really in the last year to year and a
half our focus is shifted more from
speed and shift it to be the most
accurate possible assembler and so
really the focus has been in that area
now
and and we've seen some nice
improvements right now our accuracy who
does make kind of one general statement
this is with alumina data is about
ninety nine point seven percent you know
so that means out of a thousand snips
you know there may be three that are
missed but we get 997 on average and of
course it's easy to make a claim for
accuracy and what does that mean exactly
there's lots of different ways that you
can make an accuracy claim and we didn't
think that was a good enough thing for
our customers just to make kind of a
simplistic statement and so we provided
some tools within our software that
allows customers to run their own data
sets it could be one that you've
generated yourself it could be one of
the public data sets that you can
download and run the data through the
software and then our software will
automatically calculate the accuracy
it'll calculate things and we'll go into
more detail on this so that you can
really gain confidence in not only the
software but your entire process and we
think that's something that's very very
important for any anybody that's working
with gene panels or variant detection to
really be able to validate that entire
process and so that's something we're
going to talk about today is so so we
provide this as we call it a validation
workflow so for our panels we have the
Mendelian or germline workflow we have a
cancer somatic workflow and we consider
the validation workflow then to be kind
of its own sub workflow and and so we
set it up so that it's as easy as
possible for a customer to come into the
software and set this up and sometimes
they need a little help from us and we
can help them to bed files and VCF files
and get things set up but you can really
start to improve your own process when
you have a means to validate it and so
here's a kind of a thematic for what
we're doing and you tried arrow here
maybe okay and so there are some key
components to doing this validation
process
one is that you needed a need a a region
that defines what the targeted regions
are so it's typically it's a bed file
and in this case we're using a bed file
from niste genome in a bottle and n is T
genome in a bottle bed file from arrow
right there is a high confidence region
it's it's it's it's out of n is T and
they sequence the human genome and its
genome na 12 878 the most sequence and
analyze human genome that's out there
and they sequence it for Lumina and 454
and I think solid Ion Torrent and found
that not all the human genome can be
called accurately but the vast majority
of it we'll call it say eighty percent
to ninety percent and so they provide a
region then of the human genome where
it's high confidence and endings also
supply a VCF file of known variations
that are in that region so these
variations of it confirmed using
multiple different sniffing tection
methods again multiple different
sequencing platforms and so these are
publicly available so these purple
blocks represent publicly available this
is the best one that's currently
available it is get this again this na
12 878 dataset we can plug these into
the DNA star software or the green boxes
represent you may have your own targeted
file you may have a bed file it says I
know there's variations in this you know
in this panel I've analyzed this may be
prior with Sanger data and so I've got a
list of a hundred snips that I know are
in this data set I'm going to test your
software to see if you catch all of them
so you can use either or feed them in
this pathway and what we can see down
here with with the data set we see we
load the data set into the assembler
into the variant collar into our variant
annotator and what we get in the end
then after the variant calls are made we
get you know at our array start peace
accuracy calculations and a report that
just tells us what was our false
positive detection rate how many
positives of you
what was our false negative detection
rate so it does that for you and that's
really the cool part about this workflow
is that this is pretty hard to do on
your own but most customers up until
we've had this n is T data set would
really validate just on a handful of
snips you know it might just be you know
I've seen you know whether they have ten
snips and start adjusting parameters to
try to improve detection on ten snips
where you really want to do that we've
got tens of thousands or millions of
variants to calibrate your process and
so there's a link if you go to our
website there's there's it as a link
here and different articles we have a
gin article that explains us in detail
we've got white papers that explain this
so I encourage if you're interested
check out our website so the process
then for doing a validation workflow
starts with our assembly software and
that's our seek man engine and seek Matt
engine has a kind of a welcome page and
it's a wizard to really guide us through
the project setup and so it's a really
easy to use interface that's put on top
of a very very powerful piece of
assembly software and we have different
options I could create a new project if
I was going to run this assembly on the
cloud it's really as easy as just
clicking the option putting your
credentials in and then everything else
in the wizard is essentially the same
except that you're actually browsing the
data that's up on a cloud computer
rather than your local computer
everything else is identical so it's a
really nice way to run software so it
just looks like this log in here so then
when you're loading data again if it's
cloud data it'll use this data drive or
if it's a local you're running this
locally it would be browsing your local
folders and so the typical input data
are fast cue files and so they'll have a
fast queue or a txt extension you have
ion torrent yet it may be a BAM file
extension and so we can load then
multiple fast Q files per sample you may
also have multiple samples so for
example if you have you know hundred
exomes that you want to run
certain time period our interface will
allow you to set up the Assembly of our
100 exomes if I do that on the cloud the
advantage that I didn't mention earlier
is that with the Amazon hardware you can
run those hundred essential essentially
consecutively so if you have to get a
lot of work done in a very short period
of time the cloud computers a great
choice so if you procrastinated like
like you know before a meeting and
you've got a bunch of stuff to do I
found myself in a position I need a
bunch of data done by tomorrow and so I
can launch them on the cloud you know
build or any of those if I fly to my
meeting i can go and download the data
from hotel so that's happened before
i'll admit that but if you don't have a
high throughput me need you can run one
assembly at a time or run a you know
locally on your brown computer so again
that's what the cloud kind of interface
looks like so it's really similar to the
rest of our interface so this is now
we're kind of looking at another
snapshot from sequent engine the next
step which is a input a template file
most customers that are working with
gene panels will be aligning to a human
genome reference on the DNA star website
we provide a number of different genome
template packages and these packages
include things like the DB snip filled
so we combine the latest snip
information from BB snip with the latest
assembly so the latest genome bill right
and then we package that up and you can
download that from our website so you
can see here I'm going to go back to the
highlighter we can see here that we've
got you know several human reference
sequences including a mitochondrial
reference sequence and some other model
organisms that you can download it from
our website and so the template file
then in this case is a genome template
package at this point I also load in my
bed file so if I'm doing again targeted
lee sequencing i'm probably analyzing
jeans or exons from a gene subset the
bed file then or manifest file it's from
alumina will define those regions that
interest within the genome right so your
line because alignment is still done to
the whole genome the analysis is limited
to just those readings of interest and
so a little bit of here's a little bit
more detail out of what we can do with
the genome in a bottle of data and
that's we can do an intersection we have
several of these for some of the common
panels that are used and what it is is
that the n is T bed file is represented
by this red line human chromosome the
green and the NIH T bed file says that
well about eighty percent of this
chromosome one is high confidence so
areas of the telomeres or centromere
there may be some areas that you can't
call snips accurately in those regions
but the gene panel bed file is this
these few genes scattered across the
chromosome so we can also make an
intersection bed file that says it's
really just these areas with it the two
overlap that I'm interested in that have
sniffing sniffs that are verified of
interest and so we can limit then the
region's intersection between the two
defined here are the highly confident
sniff calls in my sample and so this is
something again that we can help
customers with they want to make account
of an intersection file like this with
genome in a bottle to really get tight
accurate validations so the input
sequence files if it's from the cloud we
load them in it's from a local computer
we can see we can load unpaired or
paired reads there's multiple sample
data handling up to the top I can run
them as separate projects typically so
again it could be a large number of
exomes or if it in panels and it's an
easy setup for the validation workflow
we also load the VCF file it contains
all the confirmed variant positions so
this is the this is essentially the
answer so we're doing this alignment and
there's a set of snips in this case that
we know are there from some other some
other means whether it's from genome in
a bottle
our own means we say load the VCF file
it's a control and to validation type so
this is a very important piece if you're
going to do a validation you need to
essentially have the answer for that
validation step but it's built into our
software so it's nice and easy to use so
once you've done that you can run the
assembly and then we'll get some output
that we can analyze in the DNA star
software but one of the I think very
important points is to discuss that
we're not just doing snip calling
accuracy that because DNA star software
is producing a full assembly and
starting with raw data and bed files and
VCF files and we're actually we can do
quality control checks across the entire
gene panel so we can do things like
measure the coverage across the targeted
regions and so the coverage then is not
always a hundred percent so for doing an
exome even the very best exomes will
have about 90 we're called 95 to
ninety-six percent coverage all regions
aren't captured so we want to know if
we're doing especially a custom panel or
if it's the first time that you're doing
an exome you want to know did I get
enough coverage or is it insufficient so
generate reports and visualizations that
you can easily navigate to those areas
that were missed in the targeting or if
you're you know you know designing
primers or probes to capture new exons
and you're adding them to your own
custom panel you really need this
information to know are you getting
sufficient coverage and then also the
specificity of the coverage is if I
design a primer probe to capture an X on
how specific is it am i grabbing
pseudogenes that are closely related or
gene family members and so that leads to
overall accuracy if we have a lot of
loss in the coverage or specificity or
overall accuracy has been going to be
lower the mapping efficiency really is
the DNA star assemble in this case so
how well does sequin engine map the
reeds align the reeds lets the accuracy
there the variant filter and then also
has an impact
how well you feel they will have a
significant impact on the overall and so
all of these together combined for real
your variant call accuracy and so I'll
show you some of the interface that you
provide that makes us a lot easier to do
and give you a nice kind of visual to
look at of eternity step so one of the
first places that I would go if I if I
do my assembly and seek man engine we've
got a couple places to do analysis and
one of them is called our seat men pro
and see fan Perl provides all different
ways to look at the assembled data and
so and it provides multiple different
report so at the top here we've got a
report that is called the coverage of
target region for na 12 878 this is
constructed off the bed file that we
provided so the bed so this is really a
visual report then of that bed file and
we can see highlighted here we've got
contact ID chromosome 1 another feature
which is gene type the location right
here this column those are the
coordinates within that bed file that
were targeted then we get a length of
that region then the depth of coverage
across that region and so you can see
right at the top there's one where the
coverage depth is only 0.8 one and it's
only covered 63.6 five percent so that
might be one that we're interested in
looking at to say well the rest of them
are one hundred percent coverage maybe
the death isn't quite as good I might
look at some of those we do a normalized
kind of value on how deep that coverages
and so this report then is interactive I
can click on it I'm areas that might be
a concern and then I can get these other
views so one view is the strategy kind
of a view that shows depth of coverage
plots and here you can see these red
peaks or the coverage is over 200 over
the top of of exon so these green arrows
are CD's features and exons within the
CES so we get this strategy view we also
get a sequence alignment view we can go
and look at the aligned data
and they're all interacted with each
other so it's really the best interface
for you know analyzing in detail and as
an assembly of data there's also a you
call it a an enrichment report and so
it's another report then it's under the
same tab that includes things like in
this case not targeted areas covered
reports and so the not targeted area can
also be a concern so what this means is
where did reads a line outside of my
regions of interest so if you targeted
you know a set of genes ideally every
single read would matt just to those
limit fields of that limited area in a
reality though the specificity of the
targeting isn't a hundred percent and so
you may get significant depending on how
the primers and probes are design you
may get significant data aligning
outside that region of interest and here
we can see just by the feature list that
there's a lot of pseudogenes so what's
happening is that the targeting is not
one hundred percent specific data is
aligning back to the pseudogenes and we
can see in some cases you know it's
significant there's depth you know this
is nineteen thousand X covered on the
pseudogene so so again it's a it you'll
see this with many different data sets
but you want to interrogate that and see
maybe I have to redesign a primer probe
because I'm capturing too much
pseudogene for that primary probe so
it's a great report the enrichment
report then is a summary it's another
tab on the same in the enrichment report
then tells me things like the number of
reads that align the number of reads
that aligned to the targeted areas so we
get a read enrichment total number of
bases let me get target coverage at
different depths of coverage I'm one of
the more common questions that that I
get it regarding snip analysis is what
depth filter should I use you know it's
kind of an unknown you know there's some
people say well you know limit at the
20x some people say well 10x is good
enough and then
you'll hear other they'll say well six
or seven X is actually good enough I'm
depth of coverage and so that's a nice
thing about the validation process is we
can give you accuracy assessment at a
variety of depths of coverages and so
you can select based on real data what
the best level of coverage is not just
on you know what foot might be good or
what sounds good so when this this the
validation process is run there's
different accuracy metrics that are that
are calculated at each one of the
variant positions that are listed in the
VCF file and so again this is the the
numbers that are automatically
calculated in our software and it
includes things like true positives
false positives true negatives false
negatives FDR and from those metrics we
can calculate sensitivity and
specificity right so these are
documented again in our software so you
can understand exactly what they're
measuring so again with gene panels it's
difficult and we'll look at some of the
raw data but it's difficult to give one
metric you know in our marketing we like
to say well accuracy is 99.7 but you
know what does that really mean when
because there's a balance between for
example hitting the absolute highest
number of true positives that's get
balanced with how many false positives
are in the data as well as false
negatives and so we'll look at some of
that kind of raw data give you an idea
what that means so be again this is from
a white paper that the NSR published
late last year forget it was really this
year late last year where we have some
accuracy results and the top table is
some of the first data that we worked
with and it's the accuracy results for
the NA 12 878 exome and what we did is
we decided well we have to pick a
software that we know is really good you
know don't pick on the software we know
aren't so good let's pick on the best
one and and so we decided to compare
ourselves to the beat
you a mapper in the gatk genotype ER or
the haplotype phase caller so you use
both of their different snip crawlers
this is the the software that's used
with the alumina pipeline the mapper is
separate from the sip caller and you
need quite a bit of violent Rome at
experience to run both of them but once
you do you can get you know very good
numbers and then we compared them to
seek man engine and what we found with
now this is the exone called the Garvin
from the Darwin Institute so you can get
access to this if needed and you can see
that Abby waje PK does a very good job
so if you look at true positives
detected or maybe we'll go back to you
know sensitivity you can see that
they're all above 99 percent right so 99
percent seek man engine is about a half
percent better and so when you dig into
that to see what does that actually mean
you'll see that the true positives
detected are all over 14,000 Siegman
engine picks up you know about a hundred
or so more true positives false
positives sequin engine picks up just a
few more so about 25 to 30 more but the
false negatives were much lower and
false negatives are generally what you
want to avoid and keep that as low as
possible so bwa gtk is around 120 130
Siegman engine is nice and low at 45 and
so we think we have a nice combination
of getting the most true positives the
fewest false negatives which results in
the best sensitivity and if you look at
the far right the elapsed time we're at
least three times faster than bwa gatk
so we're a lot faster a little bit more
accurate than what we think is the best
variant calling software so we think we
have them beat on four counts now
someone might ask well what how do you
account for the difference and there is
some indication we don't know exactly
it's hard to look at every position you
know to figure that out but what stands
out here
this base is covered in the bed interval
and what it looks like when we compare
these two is that our mapper aligns to
about a hundred thousand more position
so we think that our liner is is is
doing a little bit better job than pwa
it's faster it aligns more reads gives
us a better result so that's how we
interpret that now if you look at
another data set which is a gene panel
from the same genome so this is a
smaller data set the number of true
positives here is you know measured it's
a little over seven hundred we see the
similar kind of a pattern you detect a
few more true positives a few more false
positives but only a couple of percent
more less false negatives again we at
zero in this panel on bwa gatk at seven
and that gives us a better sensitivity
right and again we're about three times
faster so we thought that was again
comparing ourselves against what we
think was the best competition we think
that we had been able to perform we can
also say this is more recent so this is
not published yet you'll see this coming
out from DNA star in the next week or so
I imagine so we said well let's see how
we compare against a commercial
competitor that is doing variant
analysis so we look at seton and engine
as compared to CLC bio and you see the
numbers are a little bit different truth
positives we can see at CLC bio to text
about 300 more true positives and we
look at the numbers a little bit more
for false positive rate is much higher a
CLC bio which is a bit interesting and
probably more concerning the false
negative you know this is five times
more false negatives and it leads to a
really high FDR false discovery rate for
the CLC software and that again with
results in a lower sensitivity and it's
somewhat how the software is balanced
there is a balance if you have a
software set to detect as many true
positives as possible without the proper
filtering you can have a high false
positive and more
descr alarming a higher false negative
discovery rate and so we think we do a
good job in comparison oclc bio the
speed differences aren't as great we are
still faster so again we think a pattern
holds true yeah the fastest assembler
and the most sensitive and we see
similar results again at the gene panel
in this case our software finds more
true positives again many fewer false
negatives zero in this case CLC is
picking up seven false discovery rates
and sensitivity we have them have them
beat so we like the pattern that we're
seeing we're continuing to try to use
these validated data sets to improve the
process and it's the only way that you
can improve software instant calling is
having large validating data sets to do
this I've actually run some more
assemblies so really this is the got the
data sets that we looked at exxon wise
are the garbin institute there's also a
couple more exomes from eric labs and
the icon institute mounts I and I these
are on the get RM website and these are
some additional na 12 878 exome data
sets that are publicly available and you
can run these through the validation
process and I did this relatively
recently just to see are you know how
consistent are the numbers and what we
actually find is that the exome that we
chose for our marketing materials
probably wasn't didn't give us the best
results we can actually get better
results with some of the other exomes
that are out there and in particular the
mounts I and I exo-m has 35,000 variants
in it we have 99.9 2% sensitivity and
the bed coverage is ninety-seven percent
so it's actually a really really nice
strong numbers with these other exomes
and very consistent and of course we're
finding more data sets are being
published and being made available will
continue to use these data sets to
improve our process
so some of the things that are coming
for version 13 there's a lot of work
again on further accuracy improvements
we've been focused on not only on snips
but structural variations you know
smaller in dells those can be a little
more challenging to detect accurately so
we're making improvements there we're
also working with enhanced somatic
variation detection there aren't quite
the validated data sets for somatic
variations I know the genome in a bottle
folks and the FDA had are interested in
having these developed so that we can
test some of the somatic variant
detection algorithms so what we're going
to continue to do work there hopefully
we get a good benchmark we can really
fine tune you know the detection of rare
variants we're looking to streamline
workflows in the future you know it's
kind of a continual process additional
white papers the CLC bio white paper
will be coming out in the next week or
so and then again there's maybe some
some database tools and hence database
analysis coming out in our version 13
software so there are all things we'll
have more information on so you know if
you're interested please get in touch
with DNA star so with that I'll take any
questions again thank you for your time
today and I'll stick around here to
answer any questions that come up thank
you
let's see
well so I have a question here from
Tammy from the University of Toledo and
she asked what are your thoughts on
variant calling on genes where the
molecular functions have not been
determined and only implied and it's so
very good question look focused today of
courses on we look at human datasets DNA
star software can work with non-model
organisms and so if you have a say a
partially annotated genome you can use
that as a template on you can still you
can create your own VCF files in our
software so if you've got you know you
may have a list of VCF files for your
organism you can use those you can
create new VCF files yeah you can view
the full analysis in a non model
organism the only thing you wouldn't be
able to do is a functional analysis so
if you if you do the sniff analysis and
get a gene set then you may have a lot
of putative function genes in your
analysis so yeah it we have full
functionality of a non model or
partially annotated genomes
you
there aren't any other questions the DNA
star booth we have people answering
questions there so please feel free to
stop by and again thank you for your
time and good bye oh I just yes I have
so Tammy has another question for
variant calling a human samples seems
like it's critical to know the function
yes and so so what I didn't so today's
focus is really on validation there is
downstream analysis and our software
that can link functional implications so
you can pull in database information
link it up with the snips that brought
the snip for the gene level and do
things like ontology comparisons and so
there are extensive downstream tools we
just didn't cover them today
okay thanks again for joining today if
you have more questions I'll be happy to
answer them from the DNA star boot and
goodbye